der schultag auch von unserer seite
jetzt wo das vorläufige endergebnis
vorliegt freuen wir uns dass wir 16
direktmandate gewonnen haben was gestern
abend noch nicht so klar war klar es
jetzt auch dass die spd stärkste kraft
ist herzlichen glückwunsch von uns an
dieser stelle an die sozialdemokraten
wir haben einen klaren auftrag von den
wählerinnen und wählern bekommen für
einen aufbruch in unserem land zu sorgen
auch wenn das ergebnis deutlich hinter
dem zurück liegt was wir erwartet und
für was wir gekämpft haben jetzt eine
erneuerung dieses landes kann zu gehen
und deutlich zu machen dass wir nicht
nur schrittweise voran kommen müssen
sondern dass wir wirklich eine
erneuerung brauchen in der infrastruktur
in der digitalisierung unseres landes
und dass die klimapolitik querschnitts
politik einer nächsten bundesregierung
sein muss das bedeutet nicht nur im
umweltressort verankert sondern sich
durch zieht durch die wirtschafts- und
industriepolitik die verkehrspolitik die
landwirtschaftspolitik weil die frage
der klimaneutralität die zukunftsaufgabe
unserer gesellschaft und damit auch die
zukunft für den wohlstand in unserem
land ist auf dieser grundlage werden wir
jetzt gemeinsam robert habeck und ich
als parteivorsitzende gespräche mit den
anderen parteien führen haben wir
gestern abend ja auch schon mal deutlich
gemacht dass das so ist dass wir vor
allem viele auch im geschützten raum
auch mit kleineren parteien gespräche
führen werden um diesen auftrag den die
wählerinnen und wähler uns gegeben haben
für eine echte erneuerung jetzt in
deutschland zu sorgen gestärkt in die
nächsten wochen zu gehen schöne haben
mit dem wahlabend durch tatsächlich eine
neue zeitrechnung in deutschland an und
wenn es nicht und ich glaube dann werden
alle leute wirklich chöre werden nochmal
eine neuauflage einer sogenannten früher
genannten großen koalition geben soll
wird es einen drei parteien bündnis
gegen das ist auf der bundesebene nicht
üben man muss vielleicht auch sagen im
wahlkampf nicht wirklich vorbereitet
worden der wahlkampf hatte seine eigenen
logik turbulenzen irrungen und wirrungen
aber dass aus dem wahlkampf heraus ein
klares mandat und eine klare richtung zu
regierung gegeben würde das kann man
glaube ich nicht behaupten gleichwohl
muss natürlich wie immer die regierung
kann aussieht sie mit einer klaren
politischen vorstellung einer
politischen identität mit einem
politischen plan sofort ans werk gehen
dafür sind die herausforderung einfach
zu groß und zu dominant als dass es dann
eine politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners des ewigen kompromisses des
[Musik]
suchens nach unten immer nur geben kann
das ist natürlich vor allem angesichts
der globalen erderwärmung und der
schlechten bilanz deutschlands co2
emissionen einzusparen die
vordringlichste aufgabe da im
klimaschutz fortschritte zu erzielen
aber auch demographie und rente sind
wichtige themen die liegen geblieben
sind europa einwanderung
fachkräftemangel und flucht denn ein
system zu bringen die außenpolitik
gerade nach dem debakel in afghanistan
neu zu durchdenken heute zu reichen
europa nach zögerlichen und nur in der
korona pandemie gegangenen schritten
wieder auf einen kurs der integration zu
bringen und das kann eigentlich immer
nur passieren wenn deutschland im
zusammenspiel mit frankreich entschieden
die schritte geht den sozialen
zusammenhalt hoch zu halten in zeiten
der zumutungen die ohne frage die
ökologische transformation auch bereit
hält dafür zu sorgen dass die
gesellschaft nicht auseinanderfällt das
sind dringliche aufgaben das setzt
voraus dass die kommenden
regierungsparteien sich der größe der
aufgaben klar werden wir haben vor dem
wahlkampf und auch während des
wahlkampfs uns auf diese zeit
vorbereitet und unabhängig von dem
wahlergebnis ergibt sich eine
notwendigkeit einfach aus den
verhältnissen dass wir unseren beitrag
leisten und ich würde sagen stark und
vielleicht auch vor allem wir unseren
beitrag leisten dass diese regierung aus
dem gebirge der letzten wochen und
monate heraus zu einem zu einer
regierung für das land und für den
menschen wird die das vertrauen das dann
mit dem wahlakt sicher
materialisiert hat auch würdig ist und
das ist eine anspruchsvolle aufgabe und
auf die konzentrieren wir uns mit voller
kraft
herzlichen dank dann kommen wir zu
fragen und die erste hat herr krämer
beraten haben sie mikrofon hält sich
länger kann es nicht weiter ziehen
nachdem sich heute morgen beraten haben
wie sieht das sondierungsteam der grünen
aus wie viele leute sind da drin und wer
ist das zweite frage wäre was die roten
linien der grünen in
sondierungsgespräche
haben es heute morgen als bundesvorstand
beraten natürlich auch wie man in
sondierung geht aber das noch nicht mit
einem gremien geklärt deswegen können
wir heute dazu zu dieser uhrzeit auch
noch nichts auf der
bundespressekonferenz sagen und mit
blick auf die roten linien wir haben
sondierungsgespräche ja noch nicht mal
angefangen wenn in diesem wahlkampf
immer deutlich gemacht dass es ein
aufbruch braucht dass es nach diesen
jahren wo deutschland wirklich schlecht
regiert wurden ist gerade mit blick auf
zukunftsaufgaben das dass diese große
aufgabe für das nächste jahr zehnt ist
deutschland klimaneutral zu machen auf
den pfad des pariser klimaabkommens zu
bringen und dafür für neuen wohlstand
und vor allen dingen eine klimagerechte
gesellschaft zu sorgen
die nächste frage herr jung
frau ihr mann habe sie kennen ihre
partei besser als als ich kann man einer
partei durch also
beibringen mit einer partei die als
zweiter ins ziel gekommen ist
zusammenzuarbeiten
aus all dem was wir gesagt haben wird er
vor dass die materialität der koalition
entscheidend ist da wo am meisten
klimaschutz bzw antworten für die großen
herausforderung deshalb begeben werden
da sollte die regierung hingegen also
das mandat ergibt sich aus der sache
heraus finde ich aber natürlich ist das
weder votum ernst zu nehmender den
erwerber hat es angesprochen oder
zumindestens angedeutet dass ich immer
gedacht ja deutlich herauskristallisiert
hat dass die spd vorne liegt wir haben
jetzt das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis und daraus ergibt sich
natürlich ein pre der gespräche mit der
spd und der fdp
es ist unwahrscheinlich dass die ihre
partei überhaupt vorschlagen könnten
nein das kann man den platzierten union
zusammen das kann man nicht sagen dass
wir werden gespräche geführt und die
sind ernst zu nehmen und erst zu nehmen
heißt halt dafür zu sorgen dass die
regierung entsteht die am
entschlossensten ist entlang der punkte
die wir genannt haben an essent denkbar
die größten fortschritte zu erzielen wir
werden sehen was dabei rauskommt aber
sicherlich und auch mit blick auf die
letzten stunden wo die union ja gerade
selber dabei ist sich aus der
regierungsfähigkeit ein stück weit zu
verabschieden gibt es eine gewisse logik
die gespräche mit spd und fdp
jetzt zu führen das heißt aber nicht
dass wir mit der union nicht reden
werden
die nächste frage frau vicky
guten tag
frau bär berg die sind mit dem anspruch
in den wahlkampf gegangen kann es darin
zu werden das hat ja jetzt nicht
geklappt trotzdem haben die grünen das
beste ergebnis seit jeher eingefahren
sehen sie sich jetzt als königsmacherin
und wenn ja
würden die zur not eine
regierungsbildung platzen lassen wenn zu
wenige ihrer themen bei spd oder union
oder fdp anklang finden würden
wir haben klaren gesellschaftlichen
auftrag weil das haben die letzten
monate jahr deutlich gemacht wie stark
dieses land eine sehnsucht nach einer
wirklichen erneuerung hat und vor allen
dingen die großen zukunftsaufgaben der
modernisierung unseres landes endlich
anzugehen und das ist das wofür wir
angetreten sind auch wenn wir unser
wahlergebnis und wahlziel nicht erreicht
haben ist dass der auftrag für den wir
gewählt wurden sind so wie sie
angesprochen haben mit unseren besten
ergebnis jemals jetzt dafür zu sorgen
dass deutschland auf den weg der
klimaneutralität kommt und das gute ist
ja an den gesprächen dass das nicht nur
eine grüne forderung ist sondern dass
das seit sechs jahren aufgabe dieser
bundesregierung ist und deswegen muss
das grundlage für die nächste
bundesregierung sein diesen part der
klimaneutralität jetzt gemeinsam
einzuschlagen haben wir im übrigen
jedenfalls rhetorisch auch alle
kandidaten in diesem wahlkampf deutlich
gemacht dass sie das zumindest versuchen
würden
die nächste frage herr müller
ja heute mühle bonner general anzeiger
dass ich hier
frau weber klar würde gerne wissen ob
dieser wahlkampf ihr verhältnis
zueinander verändert hat und von ihnen
möchte ich noch gerne wissen ob sie herr
lindner gestern mit dem angebot
überrascht hat das erst grüne und fdp
miteinander sprechen oder ob sie ein
solches angebot umgekehrt auch vorgehabt
hätte
einen wahlkampf um das kanzleramt
verändert die rollen
beschreibung beziehungsweise die rollen
ausübung das ist ja offensichtlich und
logisch sonst würde man das ja gar nicht
machen aber das persönliche verhältnis
ist gut stabil intakt und vertrauensvoll
wie eh und je und in dieser zeit die
jetzt ja über den wagen vergleicht wo
wir alle die parteien aber eben wir auch
vor der verantwortung stehen dem land
eine stabile und
gut zusammenarbeite und an den aufgaben
der zeit wachsende regierung zu geben
kann man sich darauf verlassen dass
unser verhältnis einen anker und
stabilitätsfaktor sein wird
nach diesem wahlkampf überrascht mich
gar nichts mehr und erst recht keine
einladung zu gesprächen bzw einmal
vorher selber gesagt dass wir natürlich
nicht darauf warten dass leute uns
anrufen sondern dass wir auch in
gespräche gehen weil die situation
halten andere ist wie bei anderen
bundestagswahlen es gibt jetzt keine
partei die irgendwie bei 35 prozent
liegt und sagen sagt den eindruck ich
mal an und solange könnt ihr warten
sondern das partei nach untereinander
gespräche führen das haben wir von
anfang an klar und deutlich gefragt
teil ihres plans gewesen dass sie
umgekehrt auf die fdp zugegangen wären
lehnten gestern nicht gemacht hätte
wissen sie das wichtige ist ja gerade in
so einer phase da haben wir auch alle
erfahrungen von den letzten jamaika
sondierungen dass das unglück ist dass
man wortprotokolle über das was man sagt
gut an ruft irgendwie minütlich rausgibt
deswegen gespräche vielleicht auch schon
für die nächsten tage können sie gerne
nachfragen aber mit wem man wann wo
telefoniert oder spricht das werden wir
vertrauliche behandeln und behalten
dann hatte ich als nächsten frage stelle
sinnvoll kollegin die vorne
die frage wie sich eigentlich
dass die personelle aufstellung der
grünen jetzt verändert zwischen ihnen
beiden sind sie jetzt das neue
machtzentrum der partei treten sie
sozusagen nach vorne in die erste reihe
finden sie die koalitionsverhandlung als
sozusagen entscheidende person und sind
sie auch derjenige der der künftige
vizekanzler sein wird
die verhandlung gemeinsam als gewählte
bundesvorsitzende
punkt und alle weiteren fragen sind
ebenfalls geklärt
fragen sind geklärt und in welcher weise
das gehört ja zu der verantwortung die
wir jetzt hier mehrfach betont haben
dass man gut vorbereitet und geklärt
reingeht so wie sie das von uns kennen
und es geht aber auch zur verantwortung
diese klärung dann nicht zu markte zu
tragen aber gehen sie davon aus dass wir
komplett sortiert sind
die nächste
so wie wir hier sitzen
wir sind beide parteivorsitzende das
haben wir vor monaten genau so
besprochen dass wir wenn der wahlkampf
vorbei ist wir gemeinsam als
parteivorsitzende diese sondierung
führen und auch alle sonstigen fragen
bei uns selbstverständlich geklärt
worden sind weil das geld seiner
verantwortung dazu wenn man ein land
führen will
dann hab ich vorher zu kaufen ist
haben eben gesagt erwartet und habe
deutlich gemacht dass es eine sehnsucht
nach erneuerung wäre
worauf seiten wie das ab und haben wie
ich habe immer noch nicht ganz
verstanden haben sie die frage geklärt
wer von ihnen people kanzler oder
kanzlerin würde in einer regierung und
sie wollen nur nicht darüber sprechen
oder ist es eine offene fragen zuerst
befragen wir waren ja in über 100 orten
unterwegs auf marktplätzen aber auch an
schulen an nachbarschaft wo in jedem
gespräch deutlich geworden ist dass so
viele menschen nicht mehr verstehen
können dass all das was eigentlich
möglich ist nicht nur klimaneutral zu
werden sondern auch in kitas und schulen
in krankenhäusern dass das nicht
angepackt wird und dieser wunsch nach
erneuerung der es wahnsinnig groß wir
haben und das ist das was uns schmerzt
diese dynamik nicht in wählerinnen und
wähler stimmen umsetzen können dass wir
eine regierung anführen aber das
bedeutet ja nicht dass das sein vom
status quo vom
wegducken irgendwie verflogen ist
sondern die menschen in diesem land
wollen besser regiert werden das ist
unsere verantwortung und unser anspruch
dass jetzt in die nächste
bundesregierung mit einzubringen und das
ist der auftrag von dem ich vorhin
gesprochen habe auch wenn wir das jetzt
in anderer rolle sind als wir das
ursprünglich geplant haben und ja das
was wir jetzt beide deutlich gesagt
haben bei uns sind die fragen geklärt
aber wir sind jetzt einfach nach einer
bundestagswahl wir fangen jetzt an
sondierungen zu führen gemeinsam im team
als parteivorsitzende gemeinsam mit
einem sondierungsteam was wir die
nächsten tage verkünden werden und alle
weiteren personal fragen kommen dann zu
ihrer zeit
zusätzlich auf die sondierungen die sie
gerade erwähnt haben das kommt den
besten preis und also die andere fragen
sprechen die parallelen mit spd und fdp
ist jetzt eben bisher so also fdp ist ja
bekannt aber seien auch mit der spd eva
ich gehe davon aus wir gehen davon aus
dass ich jetzt in den nächsten tagen
gespräche mit allen parteien geben wird
die potentiell in der lage sind eine
regierung in den verschiedenen
konstellationen zu bilden und die wird
es geben und dann werden auch irgendwann
sichtbare sondierungen anfangen
online fragt ulrich schulte von der taz
wann treffen sie sich mit christian
gentner also ist einfach nochmal
meisterei verisign haben wir schuld wir
dann
fragt er noch ganz grob was müsste diese
in dieser vorab sondierung sich ergeben
das was wir hier mehrfach betont haben
dass womit wir angetreten sind nicht
eine kleine spiegel strichliste sondern
ein wirklicher aufbruch für dieses land
eine gemeinsame erzählung wie man
deutschland modernisieren kann das ist
ja nichts was man dem finger schnippt
macht sondern das ist die
gesellschaftspolitische aufgabe die auch
zu einigen umbrüchen führen wird in
einer gesellschaft das heißt es ist
nicht nur vier jahre angelegt sondern es
ist auch das nächste jahrzehnt angelegt
diese modernisierung deutschlands voran
zu bringen und zwar im wahnsinnig
schnellen tempo die deutsche industrie
auf den weg zur klimaneutralität zu
führen und dafür gleichzeitig nicht nur
die arbeitsplätze zu sichern sondern die
frage von gerechtigkeit und wohlstand
neu zu definieren und das ist das was
natürlich die zentrale aufgabe ist für
die ersten gespräche in sondierung dazu
schauen mit wem kriegt man ein solches
gemeinsames bild am besten hin
dann die nächste frage dicke
ja erstmal die frage an sie beide
kommt ist für sie in betracht herr
laschet zum bundeskanzler zu wählen
unabhängig davon wie stark die union ist
weil ja doch das allgemeine urteil
innerhalb der union aber auch außerhalb
der union vor allem natürlich lautet
dass das problem herr laschet als person
auch ist und deswegen die frage an sie
ist es für sie vorstellbar ihn zum
kanzler zu wählen wenn denn die
verhandlung so etwas nahe legen würden
die zweite frage an sie habe die
fdp scheint in sie besondere erwartungen
zu setzen jedenfalls ist das der
eindruck den man aus der pressekonferenz
mit herrn lindner mitnehmen kann aber
auch aus gesprächen die inoffiziell
stattfinden können sie das scheint auch
mit der erfahrung schleswig holstein
zusammen zusammen zusammenzuhängen
können sie dazu ein paar worte sagen wie
sich ihr verhältnis zur fdp darstellen
zur ersten frage
herr laschet hat ja im wahlkampf
ein paar probleme gehabt das ist
natürlich uns auch nicht entgangen auf
der anderen seite ist das wählervotum
zu respektieren und das heißt eben auch
dass einem in einer für die republik
9 und so noch nicht dagewesen in
situationen die man tatsächlich als
ihrer übergang beschreiben kann auch
nicht nur die naheliegendste option das
ist die ampel die spd hat die nase vorn
sie wissen dass die grünen und die spd
eine geschichtliche vergangenheit haben
wir ein problem dies gehabt dass man
nicht nur diese option sondiert und
miteinander redet sondern eben die
anderen auch das gebietet der respekt
finde ich vor dem votum der wählerinnen
und wähler
es geht jetzt erstmal darum in einer
phase wo sich deutschland neu aufstellt
alle möglichkeiten auszuloten
erweiterung der möglichkeiten das ist
das gebot stunde und dann
so sind der sondierung zu führen wenn
man in zwei verschiedenen
konstellationen sondiert dann sollte die
regierung
entstehen die die möglichkeiten gemessen
an den verhältnissen unserer zeit am
besten nutzt was wir da eine gewisse
voreinstellung haben eine größe vor
erwartung dass es ihn jetzt nicht
entgangen denke ich aber
zusagen wir ignorieren alles weitere
würde ohne not den politischen raum eng
machen und da sind wir es nicht wir
brauchen eine erweiterung des
politischen raumes und das gilt abstrakt
somit das schließt allerdings natürlich
mit ein dass die parteien mit dem mann
reden überhaupt handlungs und
regierungsfähig sind und deswegen wird
man sich genau anschauen müssen was in
der union da gerade passiert
gerade in so einer konstellation müssen
sich die führenden akteure zu trauen und
auch darauf verlassen können dass die
prokura im eigenen laden haben wenn das
in zweifel steht dann machen irgendwann
gespräche auch keinen sinn mehr mehr
kann ich dazu nicht sagen zu den
personen
teams ist ich finde ich nicht dann
urteile zu geben der wahlkampf ist
vorbei und so wenig wie wir uns von
anderen reinreden lassen wollen mit wem
wir bei sondierungsverhandlungen und mit
welchem personal auflaufen so sehr will
ich das auch oder wollen wir das auch
gegenüber anderen nicht als hoch zur
schau tragen das ist die sache der
parteien jeweils selbst
und was das verhältnis der fdp angeht
glaube ich verrate ich kein geheimnis
dass die grünen und die fdp in geübter
gegnerschaft zu einander stehen bei den
fragen von steuer- sozial- wirtschafts-
politik- bei den fragen ja prinzipieller
natur welche rolle hat der staat wie
frei sollen die marktkräfte sein wie
hoch oder stark sollen die leitplanken
für den markt sein da treffen welten
aufeinander
nun ist aber wenn man nichts und das
glaube ich kann man deutschland nicht
noch einmal zumuten davon ausgeht dass
schwarz-rot noch einmal eine chance hat
davon auszugehen dass in welcher
konstellation auch immer und das spricht
eben einiges dafür dass es dann eher die
ampel wird davon auszugehen dass grüne
und fdp zusammen regieren werden da
beißt die maus keinen faden ab klar wir
hätten uns auch eine regierung mit spd
und grünen vorstellen können aber ist so
nicht gekommen dann müssen wir zusammen
regieren macht es sinn erst einmal
darüber nachzudenken ob die liegen die
denkbar weit voneinander politisch
entfernt sind irgendwie zusammen kommen
können die brücke finden eine
gemeinsamkeit gemeinsame projekte die
man vielleicht gar nicht sieht wenn man
immer nur auf das trennende geschaut hat
und das ist so in schleswig-holstein
passiert in der tat gab es für mich
schon mal eine art ähnliche situation
2017 nur etwas andere vorzeichen damals
war ja schon eine regierung mit grünen
und spd im amte und jetzt die mehrheit
verloren also man kann es nicht genau
reich
parallelisieren aber in der tat wurden
ampel und jamaika parallel sondiert und
auf einmal muss im grünen und fdp
miteinander reden und das hätte da
vielleicht eine ererbte tradition dass
man schon mal ein paar kanäle gelegt hat
insofern ist das alles nicht exakt
gleich vergleichbar aber eine idee wie
so ein bündnis leben bekommen kann und
aus einem
gebirge und gestolperte heraus
vielleicht eine eigene identität finden
kann die gibt es schon und das ist das
so hat nur was mit professionellen
umgang zu tun denke ich dass man jetzt
versteht dass der wahlkampf vorbei ist
und die verhältnisse sind wie sie sind
und dann muss man eben das beste daraus
machen und das beste daraus machen kann
das zeigen ja sowohl die ampel regierung
in rheinland pfalz wie auch die jamaika
regierung und schließlich holstein bei
all den jeweiligen problemen die es gibt
eben auch zu einer guten regierung
führen und die muss jetzt gebaut werden
dazu passt die frage von hans jessen in
der pandemie haben wir eine rückkehr des
staates erlebt wie soll eine
zusammenarbeit mit einer fdp erfolgen
die ein konträres staatsverständnis als
die grünen hat
das waren hingegen bereichen die weiter
weg wohnen ja schon angesprochen hat
also wenn man die alte ideologie markt
und staat die sich insbesondere bei
fragen von umwelt und wirtschaftspolitik
ausdrückt da muss man natürlich deutlich
machen wie schaffen wir die ziele die
wir brauchen nämlich klimaneutralität
mit mitteln die nicht in diesen alten
lagern verharren sondern durch
investitionen in innovation angetrieben
ist und zugleich und das ist die aufgabe
von politik einen klaren
ordnungspolitischen rahmen setzen aber
gerade im bereich von bürgerinnen
rechten von der frage was bedeutet
eigentlich ein modernes
einwanderungsland im jahr 2021 gibt es
zahlreiche schnittmengen die wir auch
zwischen grünen und liberalen haben und
das ist auch eine kraft für eine neue
regierung wo wir einen neuen aufbruch
schaffen können nach 16 jahren cdu
geführter regierung in diesem land dass
die gesellschaft in politischen fragen
nicht mehr auf der höhe der zeit sind
und wir auch hier wir in diesem bereich
einen neuen aufbruch schaffen können wo
gerade diese beiden parteien auch einen
neuen impuls setzen können auch gegen
die dritte partei in diesem bunde die
nächste folge harald schuster
sie haben gesagt sie würden sie jetzt
jetzt eine verständnis frage frau
berbalk sie haben gesagt klarer auftrag
für veränderungen auf nachfrage sagten
sie jetzt haben sie aus gesprächen im
wahlkampf bekommen die das wahlergebnis
ist er aber so dass die regierenden
parteien eine mehrheit haben also ist ja
so können sie erklären oder der auftrag
für die veränderung ist und die zweite
frage das dilemma wenn sie mit der cdu
zusammengehen ist das für ihre
wählerschaft eine riesige zumutung
umgekehrt bei der fdp wenn sie so scholz
geht ist es für deren wählerschaft der
riesige zumutung sehen sie dass irgend
einen ausweg aus diesem dilemma wer
meister in den sauren april wollen sie
das wieder anderen sparkassen waren also
ich sehe es nicht vielleicht haben sie
das ei des kolumbus danke
auf die erste frage sieht man ja auch an
allen befragungen die stadt gefunden
haben was sind die wichtigsten themen in
diesem land was erwarten die menschen
eigentlich von der neuen bundesregierung
auch wenn uns leider all diese menschen
nicht komplett gewählt haben sind die
erwartungen klar und deutlich dass
deutschland eine modernisierung braucht
dass wir in diesem land dafür sorgen
müssen dass die großen großen fragen auf
der sozialen gerechtigkeit das ist eines
der zentralen themen deswegen menschen
ihre wahlentscheidung bei dieser wahl
getroffen haben dass sie angegangen
werden gerade nach anderthalb jahren
pandemie und einer partei die genau
dafür für diese erneuerung angetreten
ist kommt bei so einer regierungsbildung
eine entscheidende rolle zu ja so sehen
wir unsere verantwortung als grüne auch
wenn wir uns erhofft und gewünscht
hätten dass ich das in den stimmen auch
noch etwas deutlicher ausgetragen hätte
er mich angeguckt
wie sie sagen
die partei die
in klassischen termin gesprochen wieso
man nahm sich nach nicht mehr existieren
das lager wechseln muss hat die größere
zumutung zu tun das ist völlig klar das
kann ich aus eigener erfahrung berichten
wir sind ja 2017 eine jamaika-koalition
eingestiegen die einen guten
koalitionsvertrag hatte ich weiß aber
dass ich auf dem parteitag gesagt habe
kann sein dass wir jetzt gerade eine
entscheidung treffen die uns in den
abgrund führen wird und vielleicht sind
wir in fünf jahren nicht mehr da weil
wir jetzt quasi das lager wechseln
anführungsstrichen ich glaube nur dass
diese lager welt nicht mehr die
wirklichkeit repräsentiert so ist das
land nicht mehr wir haben nicht mehr
einblick ist und ein rechtes lager
sondern es gibt auf der landesebene ja
schon lange zu besichtigen die
kunterbunten form von bündnissen und die
gesellschaft ist auch kunterbunter
geworden und die
politischen einstellungen gehen quer
durch familien freundschaften
freundeskreise und arbeitskollegin durch
gewissem sinne holt ja deutschland
gerade das nach was sich als
gesellschaftliche veränderungen in den
letzten 18 jahren 20 jahren ereignet hat
trotzdem ist natürlich die politische
voreinstellung so wie sie gesagt haben
die antwort kann nur sein dass
jeder partei sich in dem bündnis
wiederfinden muss also und deswegen
haben wir gestern abend immer betont und
das ist wichtig zu verstehen dass rot
grün zwar eine gewisse politische nähe
hat aber die ampeln nicht rot grün plus
ein bisschen gelben kit ist weil die
zahlen einfach nicht reichen sondern
eine ampel und das würde respektiv auch
für jamaika gelten folgt einer komplett
eigenen logik jede partei muss das
bündnis aus sich selbst heraus tragen
das zu verstehen ist der erste weg
überhaupt dazu kommen so ein bündnis
eingehen zu können schmieden zu können
wenn man mit dem mit der mit der schere
im kopf losläuft es gibt einen lager und
das hat letztlich ganz gereicht und
jetzt muss die eine partei quasi den
verrat am anderen lager beginnt dann
kann man es auch gleich sein lassen es
muss etwas neues entstehen und dieses
neue entstehen ist kompliziert aber
natürlich auch extrem reizvoll ist
könnte schlimmere antworten für
deutschland geben als das was neues
entsteht in einer neuen zeit es könnte
ja auch geradezu eine verfügungs kraft
haben politik attraktiv zu machen ist
eine harte übung mit vielen zeitungen
verbunden auch noch mal neu nachzudenken
wie debatten wahlkämpfe in der
vergangenheit geführt worden wie man in
der vergangenheit schön doof fand und
mit dem man jetzt vielleicht oder mit
der man jetzt vielleicht über jahre am
kabinettstisch sitzen muss und dann muss
ich ja sofort die einstellung ändern das
kabinett selber muss ja auch eine
verschworene gemeinschaft werden aber
hey es kann was neues entstehen
deutschland hallo schlaft ihr noch es
kann das neues entstehen ist eigentlich
eine coole situation also vielleicht mit
dem spirit da reinzugehen
kann ja auch eine energie freisetzen und
auf die setzen will